>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C..
>> Mary Jane Deeb:
Your Excellency,
Ambassador Hunaina
Sultan Al Mughairy.
Dr. Said bin Nasser Alsalmi,
Ladies and Gentlemen:
good morning.
And thank you all for coming
today despite the gray weather.
I'm Mary Jane Deeb, Chief of
the African Mid-East Division
of the Library of Congress
that's co-sponsoring this
conference with the Sultan
Qaboos Cultural Center.
And I will be your host today.
Unfortunately, Mark Sweeney,
the acting Deputy Librarian,
could not be with us.
As he had to travel to Egypt
to visit our Cairo office.
But first, I would like to
thank the Executive Director
of the Sultan Qaboos
Center, Kathleen Ridolfo,
whom I have known for
more than two decades.
And without whom this conference
would not have been possible.
I also want to recognize
Harrison [inaudible],
the Senior Program
Officer at the Center
for coordinating this
event and ensuring
that the wonderful
scholars you will hear
from today made it
to Washington.
I want to recognize the
work of my own team,
especially Joan Weeks, the
head of the [inaudible]
who among the many
other things she's done.
She has organized a
wonderful book display
in our conference room
that you'll be able
to see during the break.
I want to thank Wanda Cartwright
from Special Events who is
in charge of logistics.
And coordinating the
arrangements in the room,
the sound system,
the webcasting,
the videotaping, the catering.
An event like this
takes a village,
as the saying goes,
to put together.
So a word about why we are
holding this conference.
First, this is the first major
conference on Oman archeology.
Ever held at the
Library of Congress.
So it's a first.
We like firsts.
Library always likes to be
first in doing something.
At this point of
an annual series
that I started many years ago
on the ancient civilizations
of the Middle East that
included the ancient [inaudible]
of Persia.
The Phoenicians and the
ancient city of Tyre.
The ancient Assyrians.
The [inaudible] and many others.
And in June, we'll be
holding a conference
on the history of the Armenians.
The purpose is to
give depth and breadth
to the region of
the Middle East.
And to highlight the creativity,
richness, and complexity
of a part of the world
that was for millennia,
the cradle of world
civilizations.
It is also to entice you all
to come back to the Library
to our division among others
to explore our collections
and discover on your own more
about these great civilizations.
The top scholars
we invite to share
with us the research
are the ones
who will cast a spell on you.
And bring you back to
read their books and those
of others here at the Library.
And now I would like to
introduce Her Excellency Hunaina
Sultan Al Mughairy.
The Ambassador of Oman who has
been such a staunch supporter
of this project and many
others from the get go.
And will say a few words and
introduce the keynote speaker.
Her Excellency was appointed
as Ambassador Extraordinary
and [inaudible] of the Sultanate
of Oman to the United States
of America on December
the second, 2005.
She also serves as chair
of the Sultan Qaboos Culture
Center's Board of Oversight.
Ambassador Mughairy
is an economist
with an extensive
business background.
She's a strong advocate for the
U.S.-Oman Free Trade Agreement.
And has focused much of her
energy on improving relations
between the US and Oman.
Prior to her work in
diplomacy, she served many roles
in Oman's Ministry of
Commerce and Industry.
And the Omani Center for
Investment, Promotion,
and Export Development.
Ambassador Mughairy obtained a
BA in Business Communications
from the High Polytechnic
Institute in Cairo.
And MMA in Economics
from New York University.
Please let us welcome
Ambassador Mughairy.
[ Applause ]
>> Ambassador Hunaina
Sultan Al Mughairy:
[Foreign language]
Dr. Deeb, Dr. Alsalmi,
distinguished guests,
ladies and gentlemen.
As Chair of the Sultan
Qaboos Cultural Center,
it gives me great pleasure
to welcome you this morning
for this very special event
on archeological discoveries
in the Sultanate of Oman.
Today we will travel from
the northern [inaudible]
to [inaudible] and
[inaudible] and examine the ways
in which ancient Oman
served as a crossroads
for culture and exchange.
As you listen to our
distinguished guests
and panelists discuss
their research.
I hope you'll come to see
the Sultanate as we do.
A rich and vibrant cultural
hub that welcomes exchange
and interaction with
its neighbors.
And indeed the global world.
For, as we will see,
even in ancient times,
Oman was at the forefront of
the exchange and innovation.
Our last panel of the day will
transport us to the present
where we will hear about the
Sultanate's efforts towards the
conscientious preservation of
the cultural sites in Oman.
Such efforts enable us
to maintain these treasures
while sharing them with visitors
from around the world.
The Sultanate is home to four
UNESCO World Heritage Sites,
including the Land
of Frankincense,
which includes the ancient
ports of Khawr Ruri, Al Baleed
and the inland trading
post of Shisur.
And also Wadi Dukah.
Together, these sites and
others serve as a statement
to Oman's early settlement
and exchange with the world.
Including the far
reaches of Asia.
We know, for example that from
Bat, Oman was a major exporter
of copper to Mesopotamia
and the Indus Valley.
Artifacts from Al
Baleed including pottery
from China demonstrates
the reach
of ancient traders along
the Silk Route to the sea.
I would like to thank our
panelists for traveling
from near and far to share
their experience with us today.
The panelists have spent a large
part of their careers in Oman.
Their work is at the forefront
of the archeological
research in the Sultanate.
A special thanks go to, goes to
Dr. Said Alsalmi who joins us
from Muscat as our
keynote speaker.
I would also like to thank Dr.
Mary Jane Deeb, Mary Jane Deeb
and her team at the African
and Middle Eastern Division
for partnering with SQCC
to bring this conference
to fruition.
Dr. Deeb, we are grateful
for your friendship
and commitment to education.
The Sultan Qaboos Cultural
Center was established in 2005.
Our mission is a simple one.
To educate Americans and
Omanis on each other's culture.
Through programs such as this,
we hope to share not
only our history,
but our future with you.
And last but not least, I
would like to thank my team
at SQCC headed by
Kathleen Ridolfo
and also my two board members
[inaudible] and Dr. [inaudible]
who have traveled all this way
to be with us here this morning.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Jane Deeb: Thank
you, Ambassador Mughairy.
And thanks to the boards.
And now for our keynote speaker,
Dr. Said bin Nasser Alsalmi.
He was appointed as the
Director General of the Office
of the Advisor to His
Majesty the Sultan
for [inaudible] Affairs
in June 2012.
During this time,
he has also worked
as the Vice Chairman
of [inaudible] Oman.
From 2007 to 2011, he worked
as Director of Administration
for Archeological Sites.
The World Heritage Sites of
the Land of Frankincense.
He's an expert, is an
expert in archeology.
Dr. Alsalmi obtained his
PhD in Archeology Management
of Archeological Sites from the
University of Pisa in Italy.
And now I know that you
want to hear from him,
and he has promised a very
exciting presentation.
[Laughter]
>> Dr. Said bin Nasser
Alsalmi: Good morning.
Madame Ambassador, Madame,
thank you very much.
Board member of Sultan
Qaboos Cultural Center,
thank you very much
for the invitation.
Ladies and gentlemen,
colleagues and friends.
Some of them who work
actually in Oman.
My lecture is going to be a
little bit different, actually.
And I managed to do that because
I don't want you to get bored
from the keynote
speaker immediately.
You have a lot of
[inaudible] coming.
This is a floor map of the
ancient Near East civilization.
This is from Museum
of Fine Art in Boston.
What you can see there is the
most important civilization
in the Middle East.
What you can see in the Arabian
Peninsula there is only one
name exists.
Oman always been a focal point
in the international trade.
You have it from the
Frankincense Trail
down from Dhofar all the
way to the Red Sea to Europe
or with [inaudible], with Magan
from the third millennium BC.
All the way to Mesopotamia
or the Indus Valley.
And by margin, both of
those trades, you have one
of the oldest evidence
of a human being
or human existence in Arabia.
This is how Oman today
with its boundaries.
Oman was in a political
it was bigger than that,
getting bigger, getting smaller.
But this is how is Oman today.
It's still a focal point in the
trade, in international trade.
And it's still a focal
point in history.
This is our masterpiece.
This is an axe dated to two
million years ago was found
in a [inaudible] in Dhofar.
If we go back, I'm sorry.
The [inaudible] I don't
have a pointer here.
[Inaudible] the [inaudible] of
Dhofar is between the Mountain
of Dhofar, all the way to
Al Wusta, so all that desert
in the middle of Oman, this
is the [inaudible] plateau.
Hundreds of archeological
sites been discovered there.
Goes back from two millions
years ago until the first vic--
settlement, goes to the tenth
millennium BC [inaudible]
or in [inaudible].
Between them, you
have [inaudible] goes
to 450,000 years ago,
120,000 years ago.
And it's a long list
of archeology.
I'm going to give you actually
the-- we have two sites.
Came up with very
interesting results.
It's not been published
yet, so I'm going
to focus on those two sites.
[inaudible] it's about
[inaudible] and Khawr Ruri.
Khawr Ruri is World Heritage
Site of the Land of Frankincense
as Her Ex, Her Excellency the
Ambassador mentioned the Land
of Frankincense sites.
One of them is Khawr Ruri.
Two years ago, we did
a kind of investigation
with an Italian Mission to
Oman from Pisa University
and the discovery was amazing.
This is a [inaudible].
You have a fortified site.
Give you an evidence
from 60,000 BC.
This is the first evidence.
We have it in [inaudible] on
the coastline that it goes back
to the 60,000 years ago.
Normally we have much of the
site are on the [inaudible].
Here you can see
the differentiate
between political
site [inaudible].
You have from the 60,000.
You have from [inaudible]
6000, and you have Bronze Age.
Then you have-- we
call it [inaudible].
We don't call it
Islamic Period, actually.
This is the site.
This is the main gate.
It's 100 meter above sea.
So you have to climb
up, I think.
Some of you [inaudible]
she was there already.
She knows that area.
This is the site
of the Bronze Age.
This one here is the most
[inaudible] Bronze sites.
We find it in Dhofar.
Little bit different that
we find it on the top
of [inaudible] because
it's above the sea.
This is oldest [inaudible]
that we have it in Khawr Ruri.
From there we believe
that they moved down to,
and they built somehow around,
somehow around the five
century BC all the way
to the fourth century BC.
No, the fourth century
AD actually.
This is the most
interesting artifact
that for the first time we
find them on the coastline
of Dhofar, 60,000 years ago.
Some of similar object
you will find them
in the [inaudible]
plateau in the desert.
But to have it on the coastline,
we have one of the earliest
evidence of human presence
and occupation in Dhofar.
And this is from the Neolithic
Period, 6000 years ago.
[Inaudible] is little bit,
we actually I have this
in a conversation with Professor
Jeffery [inaudible] three weeks,
four weeks ago before
I came back to Oman.
No, before I come, before
I came to Washington.
For him, he was looking
to this site.
And the site is in
a small valley.
It's that, it's that thick.
He waited for the analysis to
come back and he was shocked
because he believed this was
not more than 12,000 years ago.
Analysis give it, this is one
of the oldest occupation coming
in this area [inaudible]
which is 30,000 years ago.
Why is [inaudible]
important for us?
It's connected what we believe
in our, in our literature
with [inaudible] people.
That [inaudible] people
occupied this area
and it's been destroyed by a
wind, et cetera, et cetera.
At the end of this
lecture actually,
I have eight minutes [inaudible]
that will give you the
idea how wide this area
and how it became as a desert.
So this is one of
the most interesting.
This is only one month ago
discovery and analysis.
This is the whole plateau.
You can see the [inaudible]
complicated,
but you can see the wadis there.
This is the artifact
that we find in there.
Very small artifacts.
The [inaudible] plateau is one
of the most interesting part
of Oman which has a lot
of archeological site.
Coming from early
Neolithic Period.
And of course is goes inside
[inaudible] which is part
of [inaudible] in
this, in this area.
This is the area what we believe
that [inaudible]
people used to live in.
And this is the site.
After the banishment,
they just distributed
in small groups around 20, 25's.
And they start to build,
not to build actually.
They start to establish their
own small settlements around it.
And it's continue
all the way to Sur.
So we have the [inaudible]
area from Sur.
From [inaudible]
in Sur all the way
down to [inaudible] in Yemen.
The most site that I
really been working
in was Salut in the north.
Salut for us is important
of two reason.
It's connected to the
legendary of [inaudible]
when he was traveling from
[inaudible] he arrived to Salut.
And he found a palace
and it was uninhabited.
[Inaudible] what's
happened to the people?
And he ask the [inaudible]
to construct the palace.
So according to the legend,
in three days he
constructed something
like 30,000 [inaudible] in Oman.
Of course that's the legend.
That's why Salut
for us important.
We inscribe the word,
the [inaudible] World
Heritage Site according
to our discovery actually in
Salut would give us evidence,
the earliest irrigation channel
system in Oman goes back--
or in the area, actually,
to the third millennium BC.
This is Salut in 2004.
And this is Salut 2017.
This is the-- we, we, you,
we start to [inaudible]
at the village.
But later on archeologists told
us this is not a [inaudible]
this is well-advanced system.
Well organized.
And it's [inaudible] in Salut.
The site is huge.
The site is on the tentative
list for World Heritage Sites.
We started now to establish
as an archeological park.
We have already done
two archeological parks
down in [inaudible].
One in [inaudible]
and one in Khawr Ruri.
Reason last year [inaudible],
last year again we
added [inaudible]
as an archeological
park as well.
So this is give you an idea
of the importance of Salut.
In Salut, we have something
like more than 3000 tombs
on the top of the mountains.
It's a long process.
We believe it's the
heart of Oman.
This is lead me to the second
point why is Salut important?
In the Omani literature as well.
It's where [inaudible]
defeated [inaudible]
around first century AD.
And we started with what we
call it [inaudible] of Oman
and Oman become more
part of Arabic identity.
Two months ago, we had an
Italian mission work in Oman
and we discovered
a large cemetery.
And we within a lot of
weapons, lot of swords.
The, the primary analysis
give us this is coming
to the first century AD
which is close to the battle
that took place with
the [inaudible].
So we might discover what
they call it the, the,
the tomb of [inaudible].
Are they soldiers?
We don't know.
But this is the [inaudible]
Salut.
Until two, three years
ago we didn't thought
that there is anything
underneath.
It just a small wall
need to be restored.
Need to be conserved.
And to be drawing [inaudible].
Later on we discovered that
we had a complete close
to [inaudible] goes back
to the third millennium BC.
We, a city has all the
elements as an administrative
and ruling area for [inaudible].
We believe, I'm not sure
about it, but we believe
that it might be the capital of
[inaudible] but we are not sure.
We are still with analysis
and we'll see how it goes.
This is one of the tombs.
Part of our work is
actually to make a kind
of a presentation to the public.
Public awareness is
very important for us.
It is very important
that they, they know
and understand what
we have been doing.
Because we have always the
argument what the benefit
of archeology?
We are spending money,
so what the benefit?
The example we have it in
Khawr Ruri and in Al Baleed
with a visitors close to
200,000 visitors a year.
I think that justify why
we have to concentrate
on archeological past.
Why we have to set
up this example
as an archeological
park in Oman.
And actually recently we
manage with US [inaudible]
and income to, to
pass a recommendation
about archeological park.
We call it [inaudible]
recommendation
on archeological park.
For the first time with
[inaudible] to approve the term
and the concepts, the
principle of archeological park.
This is one of the tomb.
This is the third
millennium BC tomb.
This is actually on the
top of the mountains.
Restoration process continue.
And this is how it look
after it has been restored.
This is, it would be amazing
to see that people they go
and climb the mountain
just to see it, you know.
It's not easy to reach
the top of the mountain.
But people, they love to see it.
Especially the local community.
It's been, they've been
there for hundred of years.
They never give any
attention what's going on.
As soon we made few examples
of restoration excavation
in the area.
We have a lot of demand
of people that are coming
and asking, "What does it mean?
How old is this site?
What kind of discovery
you find there?"
The area as one hand, what we
call them is a third millennium
BC towers.
This is, you'll find
them a lot in the north
of Oman what we call it Omani
Peninsula which is now Oman
and United Arab Emirates.
You'll find them in [inaudible],
you find them in Bat.
We believe they are a kind
of protection towers been
distributed in certain area
of Oman and in certain
area of valleys.
And most of them, they
have a wadi inside
so they are more independent
and they can collect water.
Salut is 150-- no, it's
200 kilometer inside Oman.
So it's on the close to
[inaudible] mountain.
However, this is a scene
from the Indus Valley
to show you the trade between
Oman and the Indus Valley.
It's not on the coastline
and you are talking
about the third millennium city.
You are talking about
5000 years ago
that there was a trade
established between Salut
in the heart of Oman
and Indus Valley.
We know in those days
that already Oman
maritime history started
with the [inaudible] from
[inaudible] all the way to,
to Indus Valley, all the,
all the way to India.
But to have those kind
of [inaudible] give you
that Salut is very important.
There was an administrative
structure.
Because [inaudible]
mean it's a stamp.
Something is a property.
You are trying to prove
that this is yours.
You're trying to, to establish
or to accomplish a
deal with someone.
So you have a structure
of administrative system
already exist in Salut.
Snakes. We believe
that the people
of Salut worshipped snakes.
And it's a sign of protection.
Recently with the Ministry
of Culture and Heritage close
to [inaudible] which another
100 kilometer from Salut.
They discover another
site, and they have snakes.
You have it in bronze,
you have it in pottery.
You have it as the, as what they
call it, in what you call it,
impressed on the pottery itself.
According to the
legend of Frankincense,
the frankincense trees been
protected by flying snakes.
We are talking about [inaudible]
in the south which is something
like 1000 kilometer away.
This is little bit-- we had
a big argument about it.
We discover five, six actually.
No, five completed
base for, for columns.
We reconstructed according
to UNESCO standards.
We try to, to adapt the
Omani traditional architect.
Because we have [inaudible].
We have the columns with the,
with the base on the top.
And we have the roofs.
Close by to, to Salut
you have Bahla.
Bahla it goes-- the
area's occupation of Bahla
of the Bahla fort is
going to the [inaudible]
which is we are talking
about around 100 BC.
The same technique until
now has been used in Oman
with mosques, with forts.
And this is the first time
that we discovered
in Arabian Peninsula.
It has a kind of
[inaudible] influence.
This is again, on
the top of Salut.
That mean you have to climb
for half an hour just
to get [inaudible].
I'm, I'm going to close
my, my presentation
with archeological parks
because we work hard,
we work very long,
very intensive.
We started with US
archeological park.
And they made wonderful
study for us in the nineties.
This is [inaudible].
It was discovered in 1989 then
with Trans Arabia,
with Professor-- .
[ Inaudible ]
Participated in the
excavation in those days.
And the Lost City of
Ubar as some people there
like to say, to call it.
We call it one of the
station for the Land
of Frankincense Trade
because Land
of Frankincense Trade,
you have two routes.
The sea routes come from Khawr
Ruri to [inaudible] and goes
to the Red Sea all
the way to, to Greece.
Or by road, I'm sorry,
by land, land routes goes
to [inaudible] to Shisur.
And from Shisur go
to [inaudible]
in inside [inaudible] in
the [inaudible] quarter
and from there to the north.
What's the important
of this site is water.
Because [inaudible] trade
with, with the local for water.
I will summarize
everything I said
in this eight film animation.
I hope you will like
it because this is part
of our interpretation in
the archeological park.
We establish information
center, people can go.
People can be informative,
not educated but informative.
They can see what the sites
looks like, how it was,
and the long history
of the site.
The long process.
We spent something like more
than 25 years working in Shisur
from during the time
period from excavation,
analysis, restoration.
And sometimes we have to get a
very professional company just
to-- we go back.
Just to stabilize the cave.
Because the cave was collapsing.
The water level went down.
There was a-- and all
this area was collapsed.
So we have to stab--
to stabilize the cave,
otherwise we are going
to lose the site.
This is the advantage to
be a World Heritage Site,
that you have to spend
a lot of money in size.
And then later on you don't
know what to do with is.
Can I have the light off?
Is possible?
Is not? Okay.
I hope-- this is a film
summarize how wide the
[inaudible] plateau.
It's eight minutes.
I hope you have patience
for that.
>> Listen.
Can't you hear it?
>> What should we hear, Grandpa?
>> I cannot hear anything.
>> Exactly.
Great stories are
born from silence.
The fire makes us tell them,
and the stars turn
them into legends.
I have a story to tell you.
The story of how a garden
became sand and was split.
And how then after many
centuries has returned
to unite and flourish.
>> Listen.
It's [inaudible].
>> A long time ago, Ubar
was a garden rich in water,
trees and [inaudible].
Travelers that saw it tell of
beautiful horses and gazelles.
And big palm trees
with golden dates,
where singing birds
chased each other.
Water flew in great falls.
And vast lakes extended
where now there is only
an expanse of desert.
Our ancestors lived
a simple life.
Hunting and cultivating animals,
working with tools
made of stone.
>> And then what happened?
>> Water began to run out.
The rivers and the
lakes dried up.
Our tradition speaks of a reason
for such dramatic climate change
in all of the Arabian Peninsula.
It was the time of the of
[inaudible] to build landmarks
to indicate the right way
to the fresh water
springs of their people.
They put up three upright stones
and a force to cover them.
The cover was the sky,
and the upright stones,
the pillars of the
earth, helping it stay up.
The people of [inaudible] were
rich but refused to listen
to the message of the
righteous prophet [inaudible].
Instead of protecting the water,
the animals and the plants,
they became wicked, conceited,
tyrannical, and arrogant.
The people of [inaudible]
became ungrateful
and misused the Almighty's
blessing.
The punishment came.
Changing weather
stopped the cool rain.
The green land became dry.
The Almighty sent a
wind from the desert,
and nature was transformed.
For seven nights and eight days,
the wind blew hard
and relentlessly.
Mountains were destroyed,
trees uprooted
as if they were grains of sand.
And the people fell as if
they were the hollow trunks
of palm trees.
Except for those who
believed in Prophet Hud.
Peace be upon him.
His tomb is located in
the Dhofar mountains.
>> A sad end for them, and
a beginning for the desert.
>> Did everybody die?
>> No, those faithful to Hud's
teachings were saved and moved
to the west, south, and north.
From Oman until [inaudible].
Do you recognize this?
We still use it.
>> A line in the sand.
A road.
>> This is the road that linked
the south and north of Oman.
In the north of Oman,
there were other cities.
Six thousand years ago, people
learned to live together,
to write, and to build.
In Mesopotamia, Syria,
and Egypt, great realms
and empires were formed.
So Oman had a part to play
at the beginning of history.
>> And the water?
>> Our ancestors had to
face a dramatic situation.
And search for water
where it was hiding.
Underground.
They dug wells and built canals.
>> The Aflaj?
>> The Aflaj.
One of the most daring
engineering feats
of the ancient world.
The plain of Salut near
[inaudible] was irrigated
and rich.
And then came the
time to defend it.
The Persians of [inaudible]
arrived
with a great army
accompanied by elephants.
They stopped in front of
the small group of Arabs
at the [inaudible] led
by Prince [inaudible].
The prince tried to persuade
the Persians to live together,
to share water and pastures.
He said, "If you are willing
to give me a part of Oman,
I will settle in one area of the
country and be grateful to you.
If you're not willing to accept,
I will stay against your will
and if you attack me,
I will attack you.
And if I win, I will
kill your troops."
Al-Marzuban refused
[inaudible] proposal.
>> Oh no!
>> And the Battle of
Salut was terrible.
There was nothing to be heard
but arms clashing
and swords crossing.
[Inaudible] was splendid
in his brownish-red tunic
and a yellow turban on his head.
That day nothing could stop him.
He killed Al-Marzuban.
And the Persians turned back.
>> Yes! Great [inaudible].
>> Now, in this peaceful
evening,
we are on the other side of the
ridge between Salut and Wubar.
>> Wubar, the door
to the desert.
The city of scent.
The [inaudible] of
all delicacies.
Wubar, wealthy Wubar.
>> Why wealthy, Grandpa?
>> Because of the resin
of the frankincense tree
that was worth its
weight in gold.
It came from Wadi [inaudible]
from the [inaudible].
From Wadi [inaudible] and
had to pass through Wubar.
Here the caravans stopped
in search of rest and water.
Wubar's walls were erected
above an immense cavern.
And among those empty
walls resounded the echo
of a thousand idioms, music,
and stories from the
edges of the world.
Traders from India and the
coast, traders from the desert.
Until the desert
swallowed the city,
making it the lost
city of Wubar.
>> And this is the
end of the story?
>> Stories admonish and
teach, but they never end.
They flow like the past towards
the future and feed the present.
You are too young to
remember Oman before the time
of Sultan Qaboos bin Said.
There were no streets,
no schools,
no electricity, and
no hospitals.
Then he came, a young man
full of new ideas and hope
who had traveled
around the world.
A man of great credibility,
perseverance.
A great leader listens and
does not just instruct.
And this is just what he did.
He listened to everyone.
To those who believed
in tradition,
and those who believed
in change.
In doing so, he led us on a
path that both honest tradition
and our people's legacy
but also forges ahead
with Oman's renaissance
and progress.
Thanks to him, and ordinary
Omani men and women,
our country is now
prosperous and advanced.
And our lives became easier.
During his reign, many lost
cities hidden under the ground,
[inaudible], Salut, [inaudible]
and others were discovered
and excavated.
Bringing us full circle
with our ancient past.
>> It's the ancient garden.
>> Better.
>> A new garden within
the desert.
>> Remember this hand of stories
and let them be your strength.
Be always united
and understanding
and you will maintain, with
the help of the Almighty,
a country safe in your future.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Said bin Nasser Alsalmi:
Actually, I have two option.
Either to put this in at the
beginning and [inaudible] all
of you just to listen to me.
Or to leave it at the end.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Jane Deeb: If there are
questions, please ask them and,
and if not, we'll
take a little break.
Just for a few minutes.
Refill your cups,
take some food.
And then we start
with the first panel.
So thank you, Dr. Said.
That was very exciting,
thrilling,
and thank you so much.
I will begin now by introducing
Dr. Kimberly Williams,
an Associate Professor
of Anthropology at
Temple University.
Dr. Williams is a
mortuary archeologist,
archeologist, bio archaeologist.
Whose current research is
focused on the mortuary
and landscape archeology
of Southeastern Arabia.
Her work focuses on questions
about prehistoric
mortuary ritual,
funeral landscape
information [inaudible],
interred material culture,
and archeological
human skeletal remains.
All recovered through
survey and excavation.
Dr. Kimberly leads ongoing
work in [inaudible] Oman.
And she collaborates
with archeologists
from Sultan Qaboos University
at the Bronze Age site
of Dahwa in northern Oman.
Which is located
close to the coast
and sea ports at
Saham and Sohar.
North of the [inaudible]
Mountains.
Dr. Williams holds a
PhD in anthropology
from the Ohio State University.
So Dr. Williams?
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Kimberly D
Williams: Good morning.
Thank you for the [inaudible].
Closer? So this morning,
I'm going to be talking
about the site of Dahwa located
on the Batinah coast,
northern Oman.
I first want to thank,
of course, my colleagues
who are not here but who
I rely on very heavily
and who I collaborate
with on this project.
First, Dr. [inaudible] who is
the director of this project.
And Dr. Khaled Douglas
who's the head of archeology
at Sultan Qaboos University.
So Dahwa is located
approximately 24 kilometers
from the coast, on
the Batinah Coast.
It's close to the seaports
of Saham and Sohar.
You can see here, I
think that this is-- .
[Inaudible] It doesn't
do that, okay.
So you can see Dahwa
here, thank you.
You can see Dahwa
here in the red box.
I want to start by showing you
a few slides from a presentation
that we gave two weeks ago.
We were lucky to present two
papers in Munich two weeks ago.
My colleagues and I.
The first paper was on
the settlement itself.
And so I can't really speak
about the mortuary rituals
until I give you a little
background on the, on the site.
So I borrowed some slides
from my colleague's
presentation to show you here.
So the Dahwa sites are
divided for convenience sake
into five sites, as
you can see here.
DH1, DH5, DH6, DH7, and DH8.
We've divided it this
way out of convenience.
There is a modern road that
comes through the site.
There are farms, and there's a
wadi system that runs through.
For the purposes of
this talk though,
the mortuary rituals
apply to the entire site.
My colleagues two weeks ago
focused on the remains at DH1,
so you can see that here.
This is the first part of the
site that we've excavated.
Overall there's about
65 [inaudible] buildings
at the site.
At DH1 there are 17.
Importantly at all of the Dahwa
sites, there are no towers,
and this makes the Dahwa
sites very interesting
because that's not typical.
All of the buildings are made
of rough-hewn local stone.
So just to give you a quick
view of the excavation
of one of the buildings.
The plan, and the-- to give
you an idea of what it looks
like afterwards, this is
the largest building at DH1.
This is a building called S-10.
We've come up with a preliminary
chronology of use of the site.
And so today we'll focus
on the [inaudible] Period
which runs roughly
2700 or 2500 BC.
To about 2000 BC.
The site is clearly used
for copper smelting.
And there's an agricultural
component as well.
We have lots of good evidence.
We have these burned
palm date stones.
This is pretty typical
of inland sites.
We've used these for C14 dating
and also to infer aspects
of the agricultural
nature of the site.
To remind you of how close
the site is to the coast,
this diagram I think
does a nice job
to show you how close it
is to the, to the sea.
So you would imagine that we
would have a lot of interaction
with other cultures and
with the coast itself.
We can see this by the
many different types
of shells from the site.
We have large amount of
evidence on the surface
of slag crushing mortars
from copper processing.
And fragments of
furnace wall lining.
Now, we've picked up hundreds
of these from the surface.
They're-- if you visit the site,
there's still hundreds more.
This is a very intensively used
site for copper production.
And of course the mortars.
Many pieces of copper
by-products on the surface.
It's essentially carpeted by
evidence of copper smelting.
And some more here.
So many Archeologists argue
that copper production
in [inaudible] was
exported outside the region
and not used as much locally.
At the site of DH1,
and the other sites
which we have not published or
presented on extensively yet.
There's very little copper.
Some archeologists also argue
that copper objects
were precious
and so people may have been
taking them and melting them
down and reusing them.
However, you would still expect
to see some copper
objects at any given site.
We see very few.
This hook you see is the single
bronze object that we've seen
in all the Dahwa sites
which are quite large.
Also in the tombs which
I will now talk about,
we see very few copper objects.
So our big question as a team is
where did the top--
the copper go?
Quickly I want to
also show you evidence
of inter-regional trade.
There's a large amount of Indus
ceramics found on the surface
and in excavation at Dahwa.
In particular, there's
an extremely large number
of black-slipped jars.
We're not sure what was
transported in these jars
but there's a very large number.
And so we can see there
was intensive trade.
More than 85% of
the Indus ceramics
at DH1 were black-slipped jars.
Here's a photograph
of a restorable jar.
And this graphic that my
colleague Khaled put together
showing the building of S.10 and
showing all of the jars in the--
Indus black-slipped jars that
we found inside the building.
Of course they're
not whole any longer.
They're broken, but
they're restorable and all
of the pieces were there.
We're, we're looking at this
as potentially some evidence
that they were storing
items there.
So onto the tombs.
First I want to give a
very brief introduction
to the period preceding the Umm
an-Nar Period, the Hafit Period.
Early Bronze Age.
During this time, it is, on
the hills all throughout Oman,
you see stone cairn
tombs, tower tombs.
They're on high places.
There's hundreds of thousands
of them all throughout
the Omani landscape.
And here you can see evidence
in one of the sites where I work
of the many, many
tombs on the hills.
You might find one
person inside.
You might find a
few people inside.
But primarily they're
small-scale use.
Another image of a site I work
at, Al-[inaudible] near Dhank.
And of course the very
famous [inaudible] tombs
which are of the same type.
My work has primarily focused
on trying to find evidence
of a transition between
Hafit type cairns
and Umm an-Nar tombs.
The Umm an-Nar Period is known
for its beautiful communal,
finely-built tombs that
are located in settlements
or adjacent to settlements
rather than on the hills.
So today, I will tell you about
one of the tombs at Dahwa.
We have two Umm an-Nar
tombs at Dahwa.
One is small and heavily robbed.
And the other is large and
completely undisturbed.
To give you another view of the
site, you can see here this,
right here is the tomb that
I will be talking about.
This is the site
of the other tomb.
And this is DH1.
All of this area also in the
wadi was used by the site,
by the inhabitants of the site.
So this is tomb one
at Dahwa seven.
This is after the clearance
of debris over the tomb
and prior to excavation.
You can see a large
number of wadi cobbles
that were on top of the tomb.
After one year, we
excavated the first chamber
that you can see
here on the left.
I think that's your left.
And most of the white
ashlar stones
that would face these
tombs that you would see
from a distance were,
were robbed.
And this is very, very common.
But there are some
examples of lines of tombs,
of stones that are still in C.2
in the sense that they're still
in alignment, but
they're pushed forward.
And this is one of
those lines of stones.
Another exciting find for this
tomb is this carved relief.
These are known in
other Umm an-Nar tombs,
but they're not very common.
We don't understand
what it means.
We don't know if this
person is walking
from us, walking towards us.
We don't understand
what it symbolizes.
So continuing with
the excavation,
the end of the first year,
we're approximately here.
And we know that the
tomb has six chambers.
It has a central corridor
that allows communication
between the chambers.
And this is extremely important.
I will discuss the importance
of this in a min, in a moment.
I won't bore you with
all of these dimensions.
Move on. The, the
chambers are subterranean
as most Umm an-Nar tombs are.
There is a good parallel
with [inaudible]
however the difference is
that [inaudible] we
have six chambers.
And here we, we assume
we have eight chambers.
This of course is a trench that
disturbed part of the tomb.
Very preliminary
analysis of tomb one
because analysis will
be ongoing this summer.
There are hundreds of skeletal
fragments inside just the single
chamber that has
been excavated fully.
Everything is comingled
and fragmented.
So this means it's mixed up
and broken into many pieces.
It's in poor condition,
and in some cases,
in excellent conditions,
so a real mix.
I can see evidence of
burning of the bone
and cutting of the bone.
And again, this will
be important
in a, in a few moments.
A large number of
archeologically complete ceramic
and soft stone vessels
were recovered.
And I want to highlight
the material culture here.
We found only this much
bronze so far in the tomb.
So like the settlement, we're
finding extremely small amounts.
And these are not large objects.
These are very small,
probably related to clothing
or some sort of fastener.
Moving on, I wanted to show
you this soft stone vessel
that we found which is unique.
This type of soft stone
vessel itself is not unique.
The lines, the circle dot.
That's very typical
of the an-Nar Period.
What is interesting
is the carving
of this animal right here.
I have two views of it.
I can't tell you more about it
because I don't know what it is,
where it's from, why it's here.
But I'd like to show
that to people
in case someone might
have an opinion.
Might see something I can't see.
Moving on, at the end
of the first season,
clearing the outside
of the tomb.
I noticed a bone pit that had
been ex-- dug next to the tomb.
These are known throughout
the Oman peninsula,
but not well understood.
Only maybe three or four
have been published.
So finding this was
very exciting.
Here's an up-close view
of what the bone pit looks
like on the surface.
Lots of broken, burned
fragmented bones,
ceramic soft stone, et cetera.
A close-up.
You can see here.
I'm going to stand up
again, burned bone here
and here and here and here.
So we can see evidence
of some type
of burning event that happened.
This is just what we saw when
we first uncovered the bone pit.
At the end of the season, I
was faced with a big problem.
In maybe March, April, there was
going to be pretty heavy rains.
And this tomb is located at
a unique position on a hill.
It's not the only Umm an-Nar
tomb that's known to be
on a slope, but it's rare.
And I was very concerned that
the tomb would slide off.
Or the bone pit material
would slide off of the hill.
So what we decided to do
was to dig a drainage ditch
around the tomb to protect it.
Or to try to protect it.
So this is a photograph of that.
We also dug a profile of the
southernmost part of the trench.
You can see here that the bone
pit it cut into the bedrock.
It's not a stone structure.
It was cut into the ground.
And here is a picture
of the profile,
a close-up picture
of the profile.
And from this, I can tell that
there were several periods
of use of this bone pit.
And this is a unique finding
because while many people have
supposed this has happened.
And there's evidence of much
later reuse of bone pits,
it's been very challenging
to document how many
times these pits are used.
And why. So I was able to
identify five [inaudible].
And so the next year
we came back out
and laid a grid overtop
of the bone pit.
And excavated the
entire thing with brushes
so that we wouldn't
break anything.
And so we could observe all
the potential articulations
of human bone.
This is the final product.
The final product.
And what I can tell you from
a preliminary reconstruction
of the, of the cremation events.
This was not a funeral pyre.
We know that there were at
least two centers of burning.
And at least two
different depths.
So quickly, remember
Locus 002 and Locus 004.
So at two different depths,
we know there were
multiple periods of burning.
We know there were
multiple burning events.
And what we can say is the
burning events were very hot
in the center.
But that these were not
events that were meant
to destroy the bone,
to reduce it to ashes.
But rather my interpretation is
that it was symbolic burning.
The flames would reach out
and touch the other bones.
Smoke, some of the bone,
other bone, if you will.
But it did not destroy the bone.
So this is evidence of
small-scale ritual burning
at multiple times
in, in the bone pit.
This is important because many
people interpret these bone pits
as a, a maintenance
of the Umm an-Nar tomb
where the Umm an-Nar tomb
is used until it is full.
A pit is dug, people are
emptied out to clean the tomb.
And this is just a, a
garbage, essentially.
But my interpretation of this is
that this is actually the final
portion of the burial ritual.
So a very quick preliminary
inventory of the bone pit.
Important points are
that there's no evidence
of primary interments
which is different
from for example sites
at like [inaudible].
There's no evidence
or any articulations.
So no one was put into
this pit until well
after the mortuary
ritual had been finished.
The same type of archeological
assemblage with regard
to ceramics and soft stone
is witnessed as you would see
in any other Umm an-Nar site.
Very important though.
Only six beads were
recovered from this bone pit.
And by comparison, every other
bone pit and Umm an-Nar tomb
that is knowns has
thousands of beads.
So six beads is extremely
unusual.
We also have only these
two pieces of bronze.
So again, no bronze or
copper fragments at all.
We did have one unknown metal
ring and three bronze rings.
Which is of extremely
large-- small number as well.
These soft stone
as evidenced here.
The ceramic.
These are all typical,
locally produced,
and some imported materials.
So quickly, we know
from the settlement
that regional international
trade relationships between Oman
and the Indus were
happening at this site.
This intense-- this
exchange intensified
and we have dated the peak of
this exchange to the first half
of the Umm an-Nar Period
through radiocarbon dating
and the quantity of Indus
ceramics on the ground.
But is this visible in the
mortuary archeology record?
Quickly I want to show you
some preliminary analyses
of the ceramics found.
We have evidence of imported
or imported-like ceramics
from both the bone
pit and the tomb.
Some scholars suggest
that some of these types
of ceramics were
produced for the ex--
for export to the Oman
peninsula and maybe elsewhere.
These may be examples of that.
We have other evidence
of imported
or imported-like ceramics.
Perhaps that are, have a
stronger, stronger evidence
for imports that are
not specifically made
for the exporting process.
And we're very excited.
We have also found this
inscribed ceramic sherd
from inside the bone
pit in a secure context,
about 30 centimeters down.
So it's not surface debris.
And it has an Indus
inscription here.
The question is, is
this an Indus ceramic?
Is this something that came
from Indus and was treated?
Or is it something that was
locally produced by people
who were familiar
with Indus script
and so it wasn't made locally.
Here is a comparison
with a well-known
sherd from [inaudible].
So again, there's
a large quantity
of copper produced
at these sites.
But there's one bronze
hook found
in the entirety of
the Dahwa sites.
And extremely small amounts
found inside of the tomb.
So where did it go?
We don't have the answer
to this question yet.
But I want to think about this
from the context
of mortuary ritual.
What I can tell you is that Umm
an-Nar mortuary rituals here
demonstrate and elsewhere
demonstrate that there's a shift
in how ancient people viewed the
importance of the body in death.
No longer are people
putting people,
their deceased loved ones
in tombs on high places
on mountains and
leaving them there.
But instead they
are putting them
into these large communal tombs
that are central
to the settlement.
It implies a reorganization
of the space where the living
and the memory of
the dead interact.
I would argue that this is a
culmination of the development
of ancestor reverence.
Which began in the
preceding Hafit Period.
There's a repeated perceptual
interaction with the dead.
Whereby the body is reduced to
smaller and smaller fragments,
sometimes resulting in the
final placement of the dead
in what we would consider
an invisible bone pit.
Which has no standing
structure to be seen from the,
from the, from anywhere.
Which reinforces the importance
of a common ancestral identity.
Quickly, what, what Umm an-Nar
mortuary rituals imply is
that you have the construction
of a monumental circular tomb.
You need to make a decision
about stone-crafting.
Division of chambers.
Will it be a single story or
will it be a two-story unit?
Will you have a carved relief?
Next you're inhuming
a body or bodies.
Where are you going
to place the body?
How are you going
You need to make a decision
about the material culture
you will inter with that body.
Next there's a manipulation
of the body
in the Umm an-Nar Period.
Sometimes bodies
are pushed aside.
Sometimes skeletons are
organized by skeletal element.
Sometimes they're moved
into a new chamber.
And at some point,
the bond is cut.
Next inside the Umm an-Nar tomb,
occasionally or always, perhaps,
there's burning of the bone,
symbolic burning not meant
to cremate the bone into ashes.
Next there's transferal of
the bones into a bone pit
and the deposit, I would argue,
of new mortuary goods
in that bone pit.
And this process is finished
with the ritual burning on top.
This shows you the sort of
place of Dahwa with regard
to other known Umm an-Nar
tombs and bone pits.
Nothing it known about
the Batinah, so this is a,
a new contribution
from that regard.
It, just to remind you
of the interaction,
the trade interaction between
Indus and Oman peninsula.
And quickly, I'll summarize
by saying the preliminary
implications for Dahwa are
that despite intensive
trade and interaction
with foreign goods and culture.
There's an, a maintenance of
an important processual ritual
which perhaps could
be interpreted
as the most important ritual
that a society partakes in.
How it's to handle their dead.
But possibly, even
though this, this,
this ritual is maintained
despite very heavy interaction
with Indus people.
The, there's just one
modification to it,
and that is reduction in the
interment of material wealth
which is more in keeping
with the Indus practice
of interment of the dead.
But this speaks to the
strength of count--
or cultural continuity
on the Oman peninsula,
across the Oman peninsula
during the Umm an-Nar Period.
I want to thank everybody
and, and I apologize
for misspelling Mark's name.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you so much for
your presentation.
And I feel I'm, I've
learned a great deal.
Now the second presentation is
going to be made by two people.
It's Surveying [inaudible].
A re-examination of the Bronze
Age that occurred [inaudible].
And-- .
The two speakers will
include Dr. Zenobi Garrett
who is currently
a visiting scholar
in New York University's
Department of Anthropology
as a landscape archeologist
[inaudible] explores how past
groups organized themselves
and perceived the
landscape around them.
She has worked in Peru,
Ireland, France, Oman,
and the US to explore
the wide variety
of living options
available to humans.
And the unique social
environment
and challenges involved
in the maintenance
of wherever people call home.
In addition to her teaching
duties, she has participated
in both digital and hands-on
outreach projects designed
to engage the public in
a media-friendly manner.
Dr. Garrett obtained
her PhD in anthropology
at New York University.
I will also introduce her
partner in the presentation.
Eli Dollarhide is a PhD
candidate in anthropology
at New York University.
He's doctoral research focuses
on mapping socioeconomic
landscapes across settlements
in Bronze Age Oman by
utilizing geospatial techniques
and ceramic analysis.
Since 2013, he has
completed [inaudible] work
at the UNESCO World
Heritage site of Bat, Oman.
And the adjacent
archeological remains
at [inaudible] including
leading the recent mapping
[inaudible] survey.
His research has been supported
by the Digital Globe Foundation,
the National Geographic
Society, the British Foundation
for the Study of Arabia.
And the Center for the Study
of Human Origin at NYU.
Outside of Oman, Mr.
Dollarhide has participated
in archeological research
projects in Iraqi Kurdistan,
Azerbaijan, England,
and Virginia.
Mr. Dollarhide holds a BA from
the College of William and Mary
and an MA in that field
from New York University.
So that's welcome both speakers.
[ Applause ]
>> Eli Dollarhide: Well,
thank you very much
for that kind introduction.
And also to the conference
organizers and our hosts.
And what an inspiring room
to be speaking in today.
So we prepared some written
remarks, and I think we're going
to try and stick to them in
an effort to keep to time.
But we look forward to your
comments and questions I think
which we'll have time for
after the panel's complete.
So with that, let's dig in.
We often think about
globalization
as a phenomenon unique
to the modern world.
Archeological evidence, however,
and texts from the third
millennium BC Middle East show
us that long-distance
exchange of goods
and ideas has a much
deeper history.
One of the first archeologists
to explore the role
of ancient Oman and
Southeastern Arabia more broadly
in this interconnective world
was the British Pre-historian
Beatrice De Cardi.
Much of her research focused
on the interior of Oman
and the modern Ad
Dhahirah governorate.
As part of the larger
archeological survey project
centered around the UNESCO
World Heritage Site of Bat,
we revisited one of De Cardi's
most prominent archeological
sites [inaudible] last year.
So in our time today, we'd like
to take you all on a quick visit
to [inaudible] and reevaluate
the site's significance in light
of the past 50 years of
archeological research in Oman.
First however, I think
we need a little bit
of background information.
So the mid [inaudible] BC,
also known as the Bronze Age,
was a period of intensifying
regional interaction
across the ancient Near East.
This map offers one
potential view
of how the region might have
looked during this time.
With territories labeled either
by the names given to them
in Sumerian cuneiform
texts from Mesopotamia.
Or the names used by
archeologists to refer
to particular material cultures.
Importantly, this period is
when the first cities
appear in Mesopotamia.
The Indus Valley
shown here as Maluhat,
and Southwest Iran are Elam.
This time period also saw
the development of new types
of social organization in Oman
and the United Arab Emirates.
In Bahrain, shown here with
its Sumerian name, Dilmun.
And its settlements along
the [inaudible] River Valley
in Iran shown here as Marhashi.
These broad-sweeping changes
helped foster the movement
of materials across an
increasingly broad geographic
and cultural area.
So we know about Oman's role
in this ancient Middle
Eastern world
through both cuneiform texts
and archeological research.
The ancient texts
written by scribes
in Mesopotamia an example
of which you can see here
on a tablet from
the British Museum,
record both trade transactions
and military exploits.
And referred in Northern Oman
and the UAE as the
Land of Magan.
Two Akkadian emperors,
Manishtusu
and his son Naram-Sin,
also shown here,
claimed to have launched
campaigns
against Southeastern Arabia,
defeating the 32 Lords of Magan.
Another text references
a governor
of Magan named [inaudible]
which further demonstrates
the intense interests
of Mesopotamian elites
in this area.
Though historical bias and a
tendency for Mesopotamian rulers
to stretch the limits of truth,
cautions us against interpreting
these records literally.
Other texts and artifactual
analyses further tell us
that copper was exported
from Oman to Mesopotamia
on a large scale at least
as early as 3100 BC.
Slightly later the
dark stone, diorite,
was also an important export
from Oman into Mesopotamia.
Where it was often shaped
into statues of rulers.
Likewise, the people of
Magan were actively involved
in exchanges with other groups
across the ancient gulf region.
Ceramics, weights, beads,
beads and other objects
of personal ornamentation along
with a host of other goods
from the Indus Valley
are common artifacts
at archeological
sites across Oman.
And I'm sure we'll hear
more about this shortly
from Professor Kenoya.
Ancient Magan also had
a close relationship
with southeastern Iran as
demonstrated by similarities
in ceramic technology
between the two regions.
And the presence of
stone vessels from Iran
in many Umm an-Nar Period tombs.
So to zoom in a little closer,
our area of interest centers
around the UNESCO World
Heritage Site of Bat and Amlah.
So what do we know
about ancient life
within this region specifically?
The chronology of early Bronze
Age Oman is defined mostly
by ceramic typologies and
shifts in mortuary practice.
Like we just heard about
from Professor Kim Williams.
So there are two time periods
that are culturally contiguous:
the Hafit and Umm an-Nar which
run from 3100 to 2800 BC,
and 2800 to 2000 BC via
the chronology from Bat.
The settlements in the interior
of Oman were generally based
around oasis environments.
And evidence from several sites
including [inaudible] eight
and Bat itself suggests
a subsistence toolkit
that included the
cultivation of dates
and perhaps some grains as well.
Most settlements are best
characterized as small towns
and villages, and they're
typically anchored by one
or more monumental stone
or mud brick towers.
Bat itself which I know we're
looking forward to hearing more
about this afternoon, is home to
at least seven of these towers.
The function of these
raised platforms which run
up to nearly 40 meters
in diameter remain
somewhat mysterious.
Although analogies have
been drawn between them
and the medieval forts common
across Oman's landscape today.
Tombs like those
we've just heard
about in Dahwa form
another major context
for the region's Bronze Age.
Hundreds of these
monuments from the Hafit
and the larger structures
from the Umm an-Nar Period
dot the landscape around Bat
and its surrounding settlements.
So one of the first
archeologists
to explore these tombs
and settlements was
Beatrice De Cardi.
In addition to being a
champion of the pre-history
of the Lower Gulf, through her
work at the British Foundation
for the Study of Arabia.
De Cardi was also an
active field archeologist.
Her expeditions to the Middle
East were largely self-funded
and conducted during
her own vacation time.
So due to her limited
time and resources,
De Cadi focused largely
on archeological survey.
Limiting excavation to
small trenches that sought
to answer specific questions
about ceramic tech,
ceramic chronologies.
Excuse me.
Her thorough surveys
and their timely
and really fast publication
provided a vast array
of information on
the nature and extent
of the Bronze Age
record of the Gulf.
De Cadi was a highly respected
ceramicist and we see her
on this slide actually
sitting at her ceramics desk.
And in the background on survey
with Oman with a colleague.
And she was particularly
interested
in what these ceramics
could tell us
about different connections
between the ancient
cultures of the Middle East.
She was particularly concerned
with the distribution of incised
and painted greyware pottery.
Which led her to Arabia in 1968.
She returned to Oman again in
1974 to explore the Bronze Age
of the lesser-known
interior of the country,
beyond the Hajar Mountains.
So the presence of Bronze
Age archeology in Oman
when De Cardi was there was
a relatively new concept.
At Amlah, she found a dense
cluster of Bronze Age tombs
and settlements and
their potential led her
to conduct small
excavations at five
of the 16 sites she recorded.
In 1976, she published
her findings
in the newly created
Journal of Oman Studies.
So like De Cardi, our
research is interested
in understanding
ancient Magan's role
within this larger
Bronze Age world.
And particularly the effects
that these global interactions
had within Southeastern Arabia.
In the winter of 2017,
under the auspices
of the Bat Archeological
Project,
we conducted a systematic
survey of the region
of the Bronze Age region between
the settlements of Bat and Amlah
in order to better understand
the relationship between Bat
and its surrounding
environments.
Shown here in the red box.
During the field season,
we recorded 475 archeological
features dating
from the Neolithic, all the
way up to the modern period
with a majority belonging
to the Bronze Age.
Around Amlah itself,
we found 148 new sites,
most of them tombs which yielded
chronologically diverse pottery.
And in one instance,
a [inaudible].
We also documented
over 80 petroglyphs
like those shown here.
Yes. In the immediate vicinity
of De Cardi's survey zone
that likely date from the Iron
Age or late pre-Islamic Period.
As part of our survey
around Amlah,
we revisited De Cardi's
original sites
that her map is shown
here on the left.
And collected additional
ceramics
from the areas she identified.
Almost 50 years have passed
since De Cardi first
set foot in Amlah.
And modern development has
impacted both the recent
and ancient landscapes
of the villages.
Of the village.
To reconstruct De
Cardi's survey,
we combined high-resolution
satellite imagery
on the ground fieldwork
and her published notes.
Using geological features
such as those circled here
in purple, red, and green.
As well as the coordinates
of known-De Cardi sites
including 3A shown here
in yellow.
We were able to overlay
her map on top
of modern satellite pictures.
We then extracted
the coordinates
of her remaining sites
and conducted field visits
to document their exact location
and level of preservation.
Our goal was to document
De Cardi's sites
with modern GPS coordinates.
Re-examine her interpretations
in light of new research,
and assess the preservation
level of these sites.
The next several slides offer
four case studies labeled here
on De Cardi's map as sites
one, three, four, and five.
On how De Cardi's
interpretations can be changed
by recent research
in the region.
So starting then at
site one, De Cardi
and her team identified
a low mound
with three cairns
surrounding a central tomb.
Though compared,
through comparison,
with the excavated tombs at
Umm an-Nar Island off the coast
of Abu Dhabi today
and at [inaudible],
De Cardi dated these remains
to the early Bronze Age.
A small trench she excavated
inside the larger tomb revealed
inner and outer wall facings.
Constructed with fine white
limestone ashlars typical
of the Umm an-Nar Period.
During our visit to the site, we
were able to identify the mound
and the location of De
Cardi's excavations.
An analysis of the
sherd she recovered
from the initial excavation show
the tombs likely were first used
during the early
Umm an-Nar Period
which runs from 2800 to 2500 BC.
And the surrounding
cairns belong
to the early Iron
Age, around 1300 BC.
Several Iron Age
ceramics eroding
from the Umm an-Nar tombs
suggest it was also reused
for burials in the
first millennium BC.
De Cardi's initial excavations
also recovered several incised
greyware ceramics.
A type now well-known
from Bronze Age tombs
across the Omani peninsula.
And from southeastern Iran.
It seems likely these
pots shown here
as the middle ceramic
picture were produced
in the Indo-Iranian borderlands,
in the area now known
as Baluchistan.
And the reed hut
architecture depicted
in their incised designs
hints at the deep integration
of foreign objects and
idea across the Gulf.
The third site identified by
De Cardi and excavated by her
as well is considerably
more enigmatic.
The publication of her survey
lists five small mounds
with many pottery sherds
eroding out of them.
And a circular structure
with a six
and a half meter diameter
and cobbled floor.
She suggested each of the
mounds might represent a small
homestead and interprets
the circular feature
as the foundation
for a palm frond
or brushwood superstructure
that's long since decayed.
A reanalysis of the ceramics
collected by De Cardi
at this site confirms the
domestic nature of the area.
Though now the mounds
have been replaced
by several modern homes
and a nearby school.
On our visit to the site,
we collected many sherds
of black-slipped jars a
[inaudible] style ceramic vessel
commonly found in Umm
an-Nar domestic contexts.
Using the ceramic chronology
developed from excavations
at Bat, it's now possible
to further narrow
this site's occupation
to the Middle Umm an-Nat
period from 2500 to 2200 BC.
The function of this round
cobbled structure is still more
difficult to discern.
Bronze Age mesic architecture is
almost exclusively rectilinear.
Though it's often
anchored by a round tower.
Though the Amlah structure's
at least 10 meters smaller
in diameter than any known
Bronze Age tower, it's tempting
to suggest that this
feature was a compact version
of this well-known
Bronze Age type.
The force of archeological
features identified
in De Cardi's survey
consists of a series
of rectangular structures
in a large stone
circle called initially
by her a wall of enclosure.
In 2017, it's easy
to draw parallels
between this associated
set of features
and Bronze Age domestic
areas across Oman.
We can now reclassify De
Cardi's wall of enclosure
as a characteristic tower
and the abutting rectilinear
features bear obvious similarity
to domestic structures at
the bat settlement slope
and from architecture known from
the nearby settlement at Ziba.
Dating these structures,
however,
remains somewhat contentious.
As De Cardi recovered only four
sherds from the entire area.
Most of which were
collected on the surface.
Rather than coming from more
secure excavated contexts.
And they all appear to date
to the last pre-Islamic
Period onwards.
A lack of sherds though is
actually a common feature
of early Bronze Age
towers across Oman.
So this absence of evidence
might actually support a Bronze
Age date for its creation.
Across the wadi from
site four and its tower,
De Cardi recorded a cluster
of tombs and structures.
She labeled the site five.
De Cardi excavated an Umm an-Nar
tomb shown here as site 5A
where she recovered material
including a carnelian bead
and a chlorite box.
She also noted the presence
of rectilinear feature
called site 5B.
And the stone robbers had
heavily damaged nearby tombs
and cairns.
In 2017, we were only able
to definitively locate De Cardi
structure 5B based on her notes
and the preserved distinctive
outline of this feature.
The remaining tombs
and cairns recorded
in the 1974 survey have
been completely destroyed,
including site 5A.
We were only able to find this
site thanks to a large pile
of white limestone
chippings and a scatter
of Umm an-Nar Period pottery.
In addition to its
spatial relationship to 5B
and other topographic
features across the landscape.
Unfortunately, site five
was not the only example
of the challenges
to preservation we
encountered in the area.
A rapid increase in
the population of Amlah
over the past 50 years has
witnessed a boom in housing
and commercial development.
Which has at times encroached
up the villages'
archeological heritage.
New plots shown here as
concrete blocks highlighted
in yellow have been
cleared for modern houses
which in turn have erased
some archeological remains.
In other cases, long-term
stone-robbing has led
to the destruction of not
only the monuments themselves,
but also their value as
archeological places.
So although we've
stressed here the tension
between modern growth in
Amlah and the preservation
of the archeological record,
this isn't to say that on a hold
on development is
necessarily the answer.
The goal of archeological
preservation
when done well is not
to stop modern progress
or deny local groups access
to new and better commodities.
Often archeologically
destructive forces
such as agricultural techniques
and civil infrastructure
have a massive improvement
and have a positive impact
on the local quality of life.
In cases where modern expansion
and historic sites overlap.
The key is collaboration
and continued dialogue
between the Heritage officers,
researchers, developers,
and of course most
importantly local residents.
During the field season, we
were able to share several
of our new finds with
the Ministry of Heritage
and Culture Office at Bat.
This has ensured their future
protection by including them
in National Heritage zones.
In this slide, oops.
This slide shows several of the
signs now marking these areas.
So taken together, this
research offers a new view
of prehistoric Amlah.
The increase of efficiency of
satellites and GPS technology
and our systematic
methods allowed us
to identify nearly 150
archeological sites in
and around Amlah, a significant
increase from De Cardi's 15.
The location of these sites,
most of which are
Hafit Period tombs,
reveal a pattern increasingly
familiar across Al-Dahwa
with Hafit tombs
occupying spaces
on high ridgelines overlooking
early Bronze Age settlements
and areas of agricultural
potential.
This corroborates earlier
work in the Bat area done
by Dr. Charlotte [inaudible]
that suggests these
high-elevation tombs
in effect set guard over areas
of potentially valuable
territory.
Our analysis of De Cardi's
excavated sherds and visits
to the sites she
recorded suggests
that Bronze Age Amlah was home
to at least two distinct
settlement areas.
The structures surrounding
the tower at site four
and the low mounds
at site three.
Rather than the pioneer
homesteads
that De Cardi initially
suggested, Amlah now registers
as a full-on early Bronze
Age settlement complete
with several Umm
an-Nar Period tombs.
Perhaps of equal importance,
however, is our ability now
to refine the chronological
sequence of Amlah's occupation.
Fifty years of archeology
in Oman and the UAE
since De Cardi's initial visit
have made massive changes
in our understanding of the
region's prehistoric timeline.
Amlah emerges from these
decades of research
as a chronologically
dynamic area.
Occupied from at
least the beginning
of the third millennium
BC or the Hafit Period.
Our ceramics work confirms
that the site was occupied
through the early, middle,
and late Umm an-Nar Periods.
And through comparisons
with sherds
from excavated contexts at Bat.
Beyond the Bronze
Age, Amlah appears
to have also been an
important area of settlement
and burial during
the Arabian Iron Age.
A time period totally unknown
during De Cardi's years
of research in the area.
Zooming out, it's possible
to form a clearer picture
of the relationship between
the large conglomeration
of settlement areas and
tombs at bronze Age Bat
and surrounding settlements
and cemeteries in the area.
Amlah's situated at the
meeting of two wadis
and doubtlessly served as an
important junction of movement
between Bat and places
to the south and east.
Our survey work in the rest
of the region are recorded
site search shown here
with yellow dots.
Shows a distinct break in
the Bronze Age features
between Bat and Amlah.
Suggesting separate
areas of territory
where at least influence with
hopefully this break visible
on this slide by an absence
of yellow dots in this area.
Amlah's [inaudible]
connections, however,
extends far beyond this area.
The presence of pottery
from Southeastern Iran
and carnelian beads sourced
from the Indus Valley both
found in tombs at Amlah.
Demonstrates the integration
of even Oman's smallest
ancient settlements
into the interconnected
Middle Eastern world.
Though very much a part of
this global ancient Near East,
Magan looks remarkably different
from the cities and kings
that characterized
the archeology of many
of its ancient neighbors.
Instead, smaller settlements
and towns like Amlah
that are surrounded and grounded
by monumental architecture
such as the tombs and
towers are the norm.
Across ancient Southeastern
Arabia, there's little evidence
for hierarchy or
social inequality.
Continued research
and preservation
of the region's archeological
heritage can further our
understanding of
Oman's unique role
in the history of
the Middle East.
And so with that, we'd like
to say thank you very much
to all the people listed here
and of course the
funders of our project.
And perhaps most
especially the Ministry
of Heritage and Culture.
And to the people of
both Bat and Amlah
who were very welcoming.
And tolerant of us often
walking through their backyards
to record archeological sites.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Zenobi Garrett?
Since I introduced you both,
I thought you were
doing it together.
Are you making presentation?
>> No, that was, we, were
presenting that together.
>> Oh, you were doing
it together.
I am sorry.
>> We'll take turns taking
questions if they arise.
>> He has the better
speaking voice so.
>> I thought you
were both presenting.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, so Dr. Mark, Dr. Mark
Kenoyer is the last speaker
on this panel.
And Jonathan Mark Kenoyer is
a Professor in the Department
of Anthropology at the
University of Wisconsin.
He has been teaching archeology
and ancient technology
since 1985.
He has served as Field
Director and Co-Director
of the Harappa Archeological
research Project since 1986.
Dr. Kenoyer has worked
on excavations
in ethnoarchaeological studies
in both Pakistan and India.
And more recently in Oman.
He has a special interest
in ancient technologies
and crafts socioeconomic
and political organization
as well as religion.
He is the recipient of the 2013
Sultan Qaboos Cultural Research
Center Fellowship.
He's the author of numerous
books and edited volumes
on the archeology of South Asia.
And the Indus Civilization.
Dr. Kenoyer obtained his PhD in
anthropology at the University
of California-Berkeley.
Dr. Kenoyer?
>> Dr. J Mark Kenoyer: Thank
you very much for the invitation
to this, present at
this conference and also
for your introduction.
It's really an honor to be here
at the Library of Congress.
It's a really phenomenal
location and I think
that this is the perfect place
for the first conference
on Oman to be held.
So thank you for
making this possible.
I would like to thank
the Embassy of Oman
for their support, and Her
Excellency, the Ambassador,
for taking the time to come
for this important event.
Also the Office to the Advisor
to His Majesty the Sultan
of Cultural Affairs, as well as
Sultan Qaboos Cultural Center.
So all of these organizations
have been very supportive
of my work in Oman.
And I-- before I want to being,
I also want to especially thank
Dr. Said bin Nasser Alsalmi,
because of his support
when I was in Oman working
on collections in the
Ministry and also in the office
of His Majesty's, the
Sultan Cultural Center.
The material that
he presented already
on Salut I will be
talking about a bit more.
And I was very fortunate
because the Italian Mission
to Oman allowed me to study his
materials and work with them
and collaborate with them.
I have also working with
the Ministry of Heritage
and Culture, Hassan al Lawati
and Sultan al [inaudible] were
the very important colleagues
who have been helping
me work in Oman.
There are many other
organizations I want to thank.
Government of Pakistan,
Department of Archeology
and the Archeological
Survey of India
because what I am presenting
today is actually a connection
of many different regions and by
working in all of these regions.
I have been able to
amass some information
that I think is unique.
And I hope that it will
stimulate more collaboration
across these borders.
Sorry. I also want to thank
all of the different projects.
I'm not going to go through
them in great detail.
Many of you are here,
so thank you
for your collaboration and help.
And many more are not
here, but they're working
in many parts of the world.
And I think that we really need
to do more collaborative work
in order to be able to
understand the complexities
of the third millennium
interactions.
You've already had a little
bit of introduction to Oman
and the history of
the Middle East.
But the Indus Valley has been
somewhat left out of this.
So I'm going to kind
of reenter everything.
And Oman is actually in
the center of the map.
So the center of the map is
not Egypt or Indus Valley,
it's right in the middle here
where you see Oman is the
center point of interactions
between three of the
major civilizations.
And, and some of my early maps
you'll see in my presentation,
I refer to this area
as Muscat and Oman.
It dates when I started
studying, so back in 1970,
that's what this place
used to be called.
It wasn't called the
Sultanate of Oman.
It was called Muscat and Oman.
So my maps show the
periods of time
in which I've been
working on this area.
This area known as Magan was,
was critical for interactions
with the Indus civilization.
And we've known this
actually since the '80s.
But I'm going to present
that this is actually
goes back much earlier.
And Dr. Alsalmi mentioned
that there's two million
year old stone tools in Oman.
I'm not going to include the
plus two million year old stone
tools in northern Pakistan.
But the question is
how do you have more
than two million
year old stone tools
in [inaudible] near Islamabad
and in [inaudible] and Kashmir,
and in Oman, and
then also in Africa?
And is it always out of Africa
or is it could be other
kinds of interactions?
And I like to always have
arrows going both directions.
So my presentation is going
to focus on bidirectionality
and not just one direction.
The chronologies have already
been presented, but I just want
to focus on the time that I will
be talking about is the period
of time when we have urban
developments in the Indus Valley
and very large urban
societies in Mesopotamia.
The Umm an-Nar Period in Oman.
But I'm also going to start
very much earlier to the period
of time that was just briefly
talked about by Dr. Alsalmi
about the lithic
periods of the Neolithic.
Because that time period is
when the first interactions
are going back and forth.
And I didn't realize it as much
when I did my dissertation
back in 1970s and '80s.
But I did study the shells
from a site called [inaudible]
which were excavated
by the French Archeological
Mission in Pakistan.
And [inaudible] the late
scholar who studied this.
And his wife Catrine allowed
me to study their beads
and the shell beads that I
was studying from [inaudible].
I noted that there were
certain types of beads here
that were not found on the
Makran Coast in Pakistan.
And I argued that
they might have come
from across the Gulf in Oman.
And I've spent the last 30
years trying to find evidence
for these shell beads
in the Makran area.
They're not present.
They're only found in Oman.
So it's very possible that
at 7000 BC, people going back
and forth across the coast from
the Makran Coast to Muscat area
or the [inaudible] were taking
shell beads back across the Gulf
to what is now Baluchistan
and then trading them
all the way inland.
And this type of interaction
suggests that people
on both sides of the gulf were
interacting very regularly.
So when we talk about
origins of pottery,
and Dr. Sofie [inaudible]
has studied the pottery
in [inaudible] and
the Arabian Peninsula.
She talks about traditions,
ceramic traditions coming
from Baluchistan to Oman.
I would argue that
these are developing
at the same time on both sides.
And in archeology, we
always try to be the place
where everything starts
and everything spreads.
And I'm going to be the
arguing that we need to look
at both directions and people
are working in both sides
of the gulf at the same time.
We also have recent evidence
from excavations in Salut
as well as studies
of the ceramics.
That we have pottery from
the period of time that is
at during the Hafit Period
that is coming possibly
from the Indus Valley all
the way into interior Oman.
Most of the focus
has been on Harappan.
This is the time
of the Umm an-Nar.
But now there's a, there's
a one pot sherd from Salut
that we're beginning
to, that we're studying.
It has the style of pottery
which we call [inaudible]
which indicates that it's
possibly a much earlier phase
of interaction began when people
were coming to this region.
Now the question is
why did they come?
And everyone focuses on
copper but there's one thing
that people forget about.
The Indus Valley is the place
where cotton originated.
At [inaudible] at 7000
BC we have cotton.
If you want to make
fishing nets,
if you want to make
fishing lines.
Making them from date palm
fiber is not very good, okay?
[Laughter] But if you want
to have nice strong fishing
lines, cotton is very good.
So it's possible that textiles
and fibers were being brought
from the Indus Valley to
this region very early.
And we're hoping
to look at that now
from excavations at [inaudible].
The period of time
during the Hafit Period,
we still see the continuation
of this type of shell.
So this shell which is called
[inaudible] is very common
in Oman.
It continues to be used in
Baluchistan in the Indus Valley.
And then the Indus people
develop the technique
for making black and white
stones that look like this.
So they develop a technique
for replicating the shell.
And making certain types
of beads that are similar
to the shell, but they're made
out of an artificial material.
During the period
of urban development
of the Indus civilization,
we see the establishment
of major cities.
Harakah where I work,
Mohenjodaro,
[inaudible] these
are huge cities
and settlements in
the Indus plain.
The Indus Valley is
surrounded by raw materials.
They have more copper in the
Indus Mountains than you,
you can shake a stick at.
You don't need to go to
Oman for, for copper.
But if you cut all the
trees in your own area,
and you have no charcoal
to smelt the copper,
then you do have to
go somewhere else.
So we know that there was
intensive copper smelting
in Baluchistan, [inaudible]
means the Desert of Death,
and this was the desert of death
because they cut
all the trees down,
and there's nothing
there anymore.
But it was a major
copper smelting area.
So my feeling is that the reason
we see during the Harappan
Period movement of people
from this area to Oman is
because there were
lots of trees in Oman.
There were lots of acacia,
there were lots of forests.
And the people of Baluchistan
said, "We can go over there
and we can get lots
of copper very easily
because they haven't used it."
And this may have been one
of the major instigators
for people coming to this area
and developing copper smelting
during the Harappan Period.
And stimulating copper trade.
So if you go to Oman
to get copper,
and you bring it back
to the Indus Valley.
And everybody else has copper
from Baluchistan and [inaudible]
and other places, how
are you going to sell it?
Is it going to be cheaper?
And the fact is it is cheaper.
Because if you go by
boat to Baluchistan
from what is now Delta to Oman.
You're going to sell
cotton and rice.
Not-- wheat, and barley and
everything else that you bring
from the Indus Valley.
You're going to make a huge
profit, and your boat is empty.
And you have to come
back with heavy material.
So you're going to bring a
heavy boat filled with shell
and copper back to
the Indus Valley.
And you can undercut the
market of the people who came
by oxcart from Baluchistan.
Or boat, by, by carrying
it from [inaudible].
So you'll be able to use
maritime trade as a way
to totally change the economy.
And I think that this is one of
the most important discoveries
of our interactions between
the Indus civilization
and Oman is the development
of maritime trade.
And global economies of, of,
of production and exchange.
So this is what I feel
is happening during the
Indus Period.
And then the question is
who was stimulating this?
Were the people, were the
people in Oman stimulating this
because they needed things
from the Indus Valley?
Or were there middlemen who
would be Omani or, or, or Arab
and Indus traders
moving back and forth?
And I was, would call them Magan
traders because we don't know
where exactly they came from.
In the Indus civilization
we have cities made
with fired brick.
And mud brick.
We have organized
transport with oxcarts.
We have beautiful beads made
of carnelian, seals, weights,
and one of the features that
we see in the Indus cities is
that people were wearing
bangles, ornaments.
And every women in the Indus
Valley was wearing bangles
and many of the men
were wearing bangles.
And we have lots of beads.
And so these types of ornaments
and things were being used
and worn by the Indus people.
But the Indus people were also
making a wide range of ceramics.
And they made these
ceramics for special reasons.
So these large vessels
have been the main focus
for the trade to Oman.
Which are the black-slipped
jars.
We've heard about them
again and again and again.
The question is what
was put in a large jar?
And based on my ethnographic
studies and historical studies
of trade between
South Asia and China,
I argue that everything
is put in here.
It can be foodstuffs.
It can be textiles, it can be
anything that you do not want
to get wet with saltwater.
So if you're taking stuff
from the Indus Valley to Oman,
you don't want the
saltwater on it.
And you don't want
the rats eating it.
So there could be textiles
and fiber inside these pots.
There could be dried goods.
There could be wet goods.
And we need to analyze these.
So right now I'm
working with the Ministry
of Heritage and Culture.
We're taking some sherds
from recent excavations
in [inaudible] with the
Italian team [inaudible] Catani
of from Ravenna.
And we are working on
the residue analysis
of these vessels to find
out what's, what's in them.
We also have beautiful
painted vessels
which are highly decorated.
Now in an Indus site,
you'll find one
or two of these vess-- .
Oh, sorry.
One thing more.
So black-slipped jars
in the Indus Valley,
they're found in
every settlement.
And you can ask me why
don't we do residue analysis
of black-slipped jars
in the Indus Valley?
Well, in the Indus Valley, after
they had a black-slipped jar
and they traded it to Harappa,
they took everything out of it.
And then it's like
an empty bottle.
And in Indus Valley,
they took these vessels,
and they used them as latrines.
So they buried them
in the ground,
and then they used
them as a latrine.
So I don't want to study
the latrine content
of every house in [inaudible].
We rarely find a black-slipped
jar that has been used for trade
because every time they used
them, then they put them
in the ground and used
them as a latrine.
So I know what's in a latrine.
But I want to know
now what's shipped
out of the Indus
Valley in these vessels.
And they didn't use them
as latrines in Oman.
They used them.
They accidentally broke.
You say them in Dahwa.
I went to the site and
I saw all of the sherds.
It's phenomenal.
So Oman is the only place we
can actually study the contents
of black-slipped jars properly.
Then we have vessels which are
the beautiful painted vessels.
And these things, only one
or two are found in
each Indus house.
They're not made in
very many copies.
So these I think were
used for rituals.
And ceremonies and
marriage ceremonies.
So then when we find
them in Oman,
the questions is why
are they in Oman?
We also find what we call handi.
Handi is a cooking
pot, specifically made
for cooking piles of
Indus Valley food.
Now we don't know
what the food was.
Probably barley or
wheat, a gruel, and curry.
We know they used turmeric
and spices in the Indus Valley
so these would have been made
for making biryani and curry.
And then we find lots
of these in Oman.
We also find [inaudible] stands
which are presentation vessels.
So this is a style of cooking
where you make certain foods,
and then you present it in a
certain way on a very high stand
which is a part of
an Indus food ritual.
And then finally we find vessels
which we call perforated jars.
And in the Indus Valley,
when we found them is Situ,
they're always found
inside a very large jar.
And this, I argue is
called a reverse strainer.
It's used for making types
of beer or barley drink
which is a special type
of beverage used in
the Indus Valley.
So Indus people developed a
wide range of food traditions.
And ceramic traditions which
we're going to look at.
And how they come to Oman.
And the Indus people
used lots of bronze.
They're probably the most
bronze-using civilization
in antiquity.
Everybody had bronze.
Because they have copper from
all sides and now from Oman.
And everybody was using bronze
to make pottery or
to make vessels.
Weapons, tools, ornaments,
seals,
necklaces, plates, everything.
So bronze is very useful.
Because if you put water
in a bronze vessel,
it will kill the bacteria
within four hours.
So people who had wealth
could have bronze vessels
and these would help to keep
them healthy when they were,
when they're drinking liquids.
So here we come now to Oman.
So early scholars working
in Oman found evidence
of Indus interactions
at the tip of Oman.
The first discoveries were
at [inaudible] by [inaudible]
and then some were found
in [inaudible] during
the early excavations.
And then later on,
people realized
that there were lots
of inland sites.
And now we have sites on
the [inaudible] coast.
So basically all over
this peninsula is evidence
for Indus interaction.
But they did not have oxcarts,
and they did not have camels.
And so how do you get a big
black-slipped jar all the way
into Salut?
Or into Bat?
You had to carry it.
Because we don't
have any evidence
that they were using
donkey transport
or carrying these
things on donkeys.
And one of these vessels can
hold 84 liters of liquid.
That's a lot of weight.
So it would have
been very difficult
to move these things inland.
But they were doing it,
and we have evidence
of those materials all
through the inland areas.
So you've already
had an introduction
about the Umm an-Nar period.
One of the things
that is important
about Umm an-Nar burials
is that within the burials,
they have very elaborate
ornaments.
Some of these ornaments are from
clearly the Indus civilization
but I want to point
out that some
of them are actually
Anatolia or from Mesopotamia
and indirectly possibly
even from Egypt.
So Oman was a nexus.
It was a place where
people were coming
from many different regions.
And the elites were using
these symbols as a symbol
of their power and connection.
My recent work in Oman's funded
by the Sultan Qaboos Foundation
helped me study materials
from [inaudible] from Bat,
from a lot of different sites
that I'm in the process
of publishing.
Which shows that some of
these beads were coming
from the Indus Valley
directly to Oman.
Some of them may have
been made in Mesopotamia.
And then come to Oman
from Mesopotamia.
And recently, this year we found
my first bead that I can say
of carnelian or hard stone
that was actually
probably made in Oman.
So the question is when did the
different technologies develop?
And how were these
communities interacting?
We also, I was able
to study the seals.
Some of these seals
from [inaudible]
and also from [inaudible].
Omani craftsmen were
using their own techniques
to make their own style of
seals which is distinctive.
They were not copying
Indus Valley seals.
They were maybe some
shared motifs,
but they had their own
way of doing things.
And then we have the
important seal from Salut.
Which it's an Indus style seal,
but it's not made
in the Indus Valley.
And my analysis of this
argues that it was made
by an Indus-trained craftsman,
somebody who has the skill
of an Indus seal carver.
But they were making
it on chlorite.
The chlorite, we don't know.
Maybe [inaudible] will
tell us about chlorite.
It could have been
from somewhere in Oman,
or it could have come from Iran.
Or it could have
come from Yemen.
But it wasn't an Indus stone.
But they were using this
stone to carve an Indus seal
so it has some slight
imperfections
because of the tools.
But clearly made by somebody
who was highly skilled.
So this means that
I'm a, I'm a trader,
I'm an Oman, I don't
have a seal.
I call somebody to make my
seal using a local material.
Which indicates a very
unique interaction system.
And this is one of the earliest
sites where we have the evidence
for Mesopotamian and Indus
interaction discovered
by [inaudible].
And then the recent, the work
by Sophie Marie and Clouseau.
And then most recently,
Sophie Marie
and I have been collaborating
to look at pottery from Salut
and also from Ras al Hadd.
And she's arguing that some of
this pottery is actually made
in Oman used of Indus style.
Now I've worked with potters
in Pakistan for 30 years.
And trying to get
a modern potter
to make an Indus-style
pot is very difficult.
Because they're Punjabi or
their Sindi, or they're Balochi,
and they're used to making
those types of pottery.
It took me 15 years to
train a Harappan potter
who makes modern Harappan
pottery, Punjabi pottery,
to make a black-slipped jar.
So to get a potter in Oman who's
used to making certain types
of pottery to make a
black-slipped jar would have
taken many, many years of
experimentation with the clay,
with the technique before they
could finally make this vessel.
Another solution would
just bring a potter
from the Indus Valley.
And bring them to Oman, and
then say, "Here's some clay."
And then they can make it.
Or they're going
back and forth, yes.
So this is the interesting
patterns
that we're trying to understand.
So this is where working
with Christ Thornton
and Charlotte Gable, we were--
Cable, we were able to look
at the materials from Bat.
We were also able to look
at the materials from Salut.
We were analyzing this pottery
using neutron activation.
And now we're finding some
interesting patterns that some
of this pottery looks
very similar
to the clay from [inaudible].
So [inaudible] is an
important area of trade
between the Indus Valley.
And I'm not presenting
the results here.
Because we're still in
the process of analysis.
A recent excavations
from Ras al Hadd
which is a small little
seaport settlement.
I mean, it's not
even a settlement.
It's less than a
hectare in area.
It's where they got the stuff
off the boats, and they sat
by the beach and barbequed some
fish and then sent stuff inland.
And we found a perforated
jar fragment here.
So they were making beer
or barley [inaudible]
we call it in Urdu.
A special barley drink
using this reverse strainer
at the beach near where
these ships were coming.
And we also found
a goblet fragment.
This type of goblet of the
Indus Valley was only used
in the big cities.
It was never used in
a small settlements
because it's a disposable
vessel.
You go to the shop, you
buy some [inaudible]
or you buy some beer.
You drink it, you throw it away.
Why would somebody
carry a disposable cup
from Mohenjodaro all
the way to Ras al Hadd?
And the only suggestion
that I have is
that they wanted
to keep a memento.
They had been to the big city.
They brought this back to show
their family back in [inaudible]
and they brought it
there, and it broke.
[Laughter] So they
get all the way back
to Oman, and then it broke.
So we found a sherd of
this in Ras al Hadd.
So the question then
is, pottery like this?
Why would somebody bring
elaborate wedding ceremony
vessels to Oman?
Probably because they
want to get married
or they're bringing
somebody who they want
to give this to as a gift.
We also have evidence of toys.
So Salut is so important because
we have Indus-style toys.
This is a pottery disc made
from Indus pottery only
found in the Indus Valley.
And you stack them
up, and you throw a,
a ball at it, and
you play a game.
We find Indus whistles.
This is a bird whistle
from Salut.
So these are children's toys.
So this means that
people who are living
in Salut are acculturating their
own children into traditions
that are relating
to the Indus Valley.
So then why are they coming?
I mentioned this a bit earlier.
They're getting copper.
They're getting shell.
And probably many other things
which we still need to study.
And they're bringing these
things to the Indus Valley
to show exotic materials
from this other region.
In return, materials are
coming from the Indus here.
The question is who
are the people coming?
Are they Magan traders going
to the Indus and coming back?
Are they Indus traders
coming to Magan?
And if they're form the
Indus Valley to Maga,
we don't find any
shell bangles here.
So either the women are coming
and they're taking
all their bangles off.
Or the women are not coming.
Because in the Indus Valley,
every settlement has
filled with bangles.
And there are not,
there's not a single bangle
in any archeological site
in all of Oman except
for Ras al [inaudible].
At 3700 BC.
So no bangles are being used.
So this is the next
mystery is what is happening
to the bangles in Oman?
And who are coming there,
and what are they doing?
In Mesopotamia we have
bangles from the Indus Valley.
In Susa we have bangles.
In [inaudible] we have bangles.
We have bangles in everywhere
else but not in Oman.
So in summary, we have evidence
for really important domestic
ritual Indus-style pottery
at both coastal and
inland sites.
Maybe made by Indus or
Indus-trained potters.
Used by Magan or Indus traders.
Who preferred to eat
food that was cooked
in Indus-style pottery.
They didn't want
to eat it roasted,
they didn't want to eat it raw.
They wanted to eat it cooked
in a handi and prepared
and served in a certain way.
They wanted to drink
beer or [inaudible]
or [inaudible] prepared
in Indus-style pottery.
We also have evidence
of carnelian beads some
of them possibly made locally.
And then Indus seals carved
with local techniques.
So I'm going to leave
you with this question.
We have a lot more work to do,
but I think we have some very
interesting exchanges now
between Oman and
the Indus Valley.
And I'm hoping that the video
can be remade with Indus Valley,
with some component because it's
not just Mesopotamia and Egypt
that are linking with Oman.
But the Indus Valley is
a very important place.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much,
Professor Kenoyer.
And now the floor is
open for questions.
We have about 30
minutes for questions.
So what is happening?
[Inaudible]
>> My thanks-- hello, is it?
Okay, my, my sincere thanks.
Ms. Williams.
I'm curious about the
degradation of your, your sites.
If you come back every
year, how do you,
how do you find your sites
that you have worked on?
And how much work do you
have to get to get them
to the, how you left them.
If that is a valid question.
I don't know.
>> Dr. Kimberly Williams:
We backfill all
of our tombs and buildings.
And so when we come back, we
have to remove the backfill.
In some cases, there
is no backfill.
And in only in cases where
the structure is secure.
>> So questions?
>> There's one over here.
>> Yeah, hi.
The question's for
Dr. Mark Kenoyer.
Can you tell us something more
about the political
administration
in these two different regions
in specifically what kind
of taxes and tariffs, if any,
were they imposing
on each other?
Did they try to regulate
the trade?
>> Dr. J Mark Kenoyer:
Between Indus and Oman?
>> Correct.
>> Dr. J Mark Kenoyer: So
the Indus cities were ruled
by a corporate rule where we
don't have a single ruler.
And the cities had
walls around them.
Anybody coming into and out of
the city was probably taxed.
We have a very standardized
system of weights in all
of the cities in
the Indus Valley.
Some of those weights
have been found in Oman.
And in prelim-- primarily
the sites in the UAE.
So we know that some traders
were coming with weights
into this area and were using
that same weight system.
We also have Mesopotamian
weights that may have been used
in some kind of exchange.
But as far as we know, we
don't have very much details
about how the settlements
in Oman were ruled.
We have towers.
We're still trying to figure
out what those towers
were function--
how they were functioning.
Whether it was with a
clan or a clan leader.
So the question is, that,
this is a very good question.
We don't know for the Oman side,
we do know for the Indus side.
We know that Mesopotamians were
coming here to get materials.
And, and they talk about
themselves, they're trying
to conquer the regions.
So I imagine that it was a bunch
of separate little
polities spread
into these different areas
with a big stone tower
as one of the main centers.
And then you know alliances
were made between them.
But we don't have any evidence
of rulers, rulers' names
or very large population
centers.
They're relatively small.
So one of these stone towers
can fit into the corner
of one neighborhood of Harappa.
So they're not very big.
So Harappa's over
150 hectares in area.
Multiple mounds.
Mohenjodaro is 250
hectares or 300 hectares.
So they're huge cities.
And then these settlements
are relatively small compared
to that.
>> For Dr. Williams.
Can you hear me?
First of all, thank you very
much for a wonderful panel.
Dr. Williams for you,
I had a small question.
You showed one little
engraving of a human figurine.
I was curious what the
hollowed-out heart would mean.
I was quite curious.
It was very beautiful.
That's one question for you.
And then for Dr. [inaudible]
is that how you say your name?
Question regarding the
connection potentially
with [inaudible]
three Persian sites
in what is now Baluchistan.
What kind of connection
do you think there is
with both India as
well as with Oman?
Also Makan and Makran.
Makran is the historic
name for Baluchistan.
And I'm curious if Makan
and Makran have any
connection linguistically.
Thank you.
>> Dr. Kimberly Williams:
Shall I [inaudible]?
The carved relief of the
small circular depression
on the chest of the individual.
We're not actually sure.
That's part of the
carved relief.
If may be.
We've had a lot of
conversation about this.
It is real.
There is a depression there.
It is circular.
There are shell pendants,
if you will.
And other pendants made
of different material
that are found from
around that period.
It is possible that it's meant
to symbolize something
like that.
It's also possible that
it's a luck of erosion.
>> Okay, the, the connections
Magan and Makran, Majan, okay?
So these are terms which are,
you know, we, we can hear them
in modern, modern languages.
I'm sure that most people know
that [inaudible] used to be part
of the Sultanate of Oman.
Until 1962 or something
like that, right?
So this was controlled by Oman.
The Sultanate had
control of that coast.
And our evidence that we have,
people going back and forth
from 7000 and I worked in the
site called Ba la [inaudible]
which is just 55
kilometers from Karachi.
And I, my student worked in
Balaji which is near Karachi.
And the smugglers are going back
and forth every day by boat.
If you need something, you can
get it from Dubai in one day.
Or two days, you know?
Because these areas
are not that far apart.
So I, I don't think we can
really differentiate Magan
and Makran.
They're, I, I kind of
group them together.
And I think they're
important to think
about as both sides
of the same sea body.
People interacting.
Many of my friends
in Baluchistan have
family in Muscat.
And people vice versa.
Have family in Baluchistan.
So it's it's something that has
been going on for 7000 years.
>> I have, I have a
question for the whole panel.
In, when one looks
at civilizations,
ancient civilizations.
There are certain characteristic
features that determine,
define a civilization
at any point in time.
As you were looking
at your excavations.
Are you able to at this stage--
I know it's an early stage
and you're all digging there.
Are you able to illicit certain
characteristic about the, the,
well the civilization?
The culture?
Something that defines
it in terms of the region
that you could say aha!
This is this type
of civilization?
And any of you can answer.
>> Yeah, sure.
I mean so I think yeah.
That's a difficult question
because there's also lots
of issues as always in
archeology with preservation.
But I think one of
the key differences
between ancient Magan or ancient
Oman and its surrounding areas.
And i, I think it's also
important to remember
that Magan is the name
given to the region.
By Mesopotamian people,
by the cuneiform texts.
So we don't actually
know the people living
within Magan referred
to themselves
as the people of Magan.
But one of the big
differences is there's
so little evidence
for social hierarchy.
So especially when you
compare it to Mesopotamia
and what's happening
in Elam and Iran.
Where there's you know
massive cemeteries
where people were
actually sacrificed
to be interred with
their rulers.
We have nothing like
that in, in ancient Oman.
And instead, it seems like
there's a real emphasis on,
on kind of community
togetherness.
And we see that in the tombs
because while there are
these kind of elite objects
like you know objects or
personal ornamentation from,
from Harappa and also
really nice stone vessels
that are coming from
Iran as well.
They're not specifically
interred
with any single individual.
Instead, they're just placed
in the tomb [inaudible].
So I think that's an
important feature of,
of the differentiates
Magan from its neighbors.
Yeah.
>> Would any of you
like to add something?
>> I have nothing.
I agree with him.
>> Go ahead.
>> I'll follow up.
But, but we do see, as time
goes on that that changes a bit.
So as we move from
the Hafit Period,
we start to see people interred
with specific objects
just for them.
And then we move into this time
where individual identity
is entirely removed
by the breaking of the bodies.
What's interesting is that
if you go down to [inaudible]
or if you go all the way
into the furthest
parts of the Emirates.
Go to Umanar Island, you see
the same exact mortuary ritual.
So that's something that there's
a cultural continuity on that,
on the northern part of Oman
that despite the onslaught
of people coming from many
different civilizations,
it's, they maintain that.
>> I would just add that
the presence of seals
with what could be some form
of possible writing is a
very important indicator
of individual ownership
and power
that links certain
individuals in Oman in the sites
that have been found in Misar
and Salut and other places
in [inaudible] that
show that they are,
they are appropriating a
form of identity that is used
in Mesopotamia, in
Iran, in Indus Valley.
But using it from a stylistic
and a cultural perspective
that's their [inaudible].
So they're not copying
Indus Valley seals.
They're not copying
Mesopotamian seals.
But they are using
certain, chlorite which some
of it is actually reused
vessels traded from Iran
that have been broken.
And it's so nice and
beautiful to carve,
that it's easy to carve.
And you use one of
those to make a seal.
But they're doing it
with an indigenous style.
So that's the stuff
that I was able to study
which really showed a
local style of carving
which is totally distinct.
And indicative of local elites.
But some, you don't make
a seal to stamp something
if you don't have
something to control.
So there are some people there
who are appropriating that.
>> Okay. Questions?
>> Two quick questions,
if I, if I may.
The first to Dr. Williams.
You, you hinted at a more
significant meaning for corridor
in an umm an-Nar tomb beyond
perhaps a practical passage.
So I was wondering if you
could say something about that.
And then the second question
is for Mr. Dollarhide.
You had made reference
to the approximate dating
of the petroglyphs that you
found to-- I can't remember.
Early or mid-Iron Age.
And so I was wondering if
you could just say something
about how you determine
that date.
Thank you.
>> Dr. Kimberly Williams: So
with regard to the corridor,
there's evidence
in Umm an-Nar tombs
that the body was interred
and then taken apart.
And pieces were organized
by skeletal element
in different chambers.
Potentially moving through the
different rooms of the tomb.
Some of them, some of the tombs
do not have multiple chambers.
Some of them have
multiple chambers,
but they can't communicate.
So there's no way to get
into the other chamber
without going up
and over the wall.
This tomb has a corridor.
And this is something I'm
working on now so I'll be brief.
But if you think of
Neolithic [inaudible]
and long mounds in,
in Western Europe.
And think of the theory
behind the development
of chambered tombs and very
similar actions of moving bodies
between these chambers over
time related to mortuary ritual
that we can't put our finger on.
I think that this is
a similar situation
because of the evidence of
movement through the chambers.
And so since [inaudible] tomb
has this central corridor
that allows communication
to all of the chambers,
I think we may be able.
And because it's
a closed context.
I think we may be
able to consider
that a little more deeply.
>> Mr. Eli Dollarhide: Yeah,
and then about the dating
for the petroglyphs.
So that is of course a
very difficult thing to do
because there's no artifacts
that we can directly associate
with those petroglyphs.
However, right next to those.
So those all those
petroglyphs were spread
over five wadi boulders.
And then immediately adjacent
to that was a large
Iron Age cemetery area.
And so and also on the
petroglyphs themselves,
there's lots of weaponry.
That looks similar to objects
found from the late Iron Age
or early pre-Islamic Period.
So we're, we're not, we're
not certain about that dating.
But it seems that that's likely
and also if you look [inaudible]
of petroglyphs with
that same motif.
Which does show up all
across Southeastern Arabia.
They're often very, very
close to late Iron Age
or early pre-Islamic features.
So, so that is somewhat
contentious, definitely.
And I will just say and there
are camels, domesticated camels
in the petroglyphs as well.
So we definitely know that it's
no earlier than the Iron Age.